[Música]
y en directo a nos vamos a Centroamérica
con nuestra corresponsal en San José de
Costa Rica sin regidores Cindy el Papa
Francisco habló este jueves acerca de
las misioneras de la orden de la madre
Teresa de Calcuta que fueron expulsadas
en julio desde Nicaragua hasta la
frontera con Costa Rica el pontífice
pide el regreso de estas religiosas
Cindy Qué importancia tiene el papel de
estas misioneras Y qué supone el
impedimento que tienen para regresar a
Nicaragua
es importante verlo desde dos ámbitos
desde lo religioso en Nicaragua se han
registrado la detenciones arbitrarias de
sacerdotes e inclusive de un Obispo
monseñor Rolando Álvarez esto ha
ocurrido en los últimos meses Pero
además desde las organizaciones
infinitas de lucro como lo es la
asociación misioneras de la Caridad más
de 1700 organizaciones han sido
canceladas por el gobierno en los
últimos cuatro años el gobierno
justifica que han incumplido unas leyes
el mismo gobierno pasó hace un par de
años y que Naciones Unidas considera que
van en contra de la libertad de
asociación estas organizaciones sin
fines de lucro han dicho que además es
parte de un intento de control total por
parte del gobierno y parte de su deriva
autoritaria las misioneras de la Caridad
fueron canceladas y fueron precisamente
expulsadas como ya lo decías y habrá que
ver si el gobierno cambia de parecer en
ese particular o en general en su
postura en contra de las organizaciones
de la sociedad civil
Cindy el papa también reconoció que hay
diálogos con el gobierno de Daniel
Ortega Cómo ha sido el papel de mediador
que la Iglesia Católica ha jugado en
Nicaragua en los últimos años
muy importante Nicaragua es un país
mayoritariamente católico tiene fuerte
liderazgo una fuerte credibilidad sin
embargo las relaciones con el gobierno
han sido muy tensas en los últimos
cuatro años a inicios de este año el
gobierno expulsó al nuncio del Vaticano
o al demark summertag en la había
fungido como mediador sobre todo para
buscar la liberación de presos políticos
sin embargo fue expulsado y en 2018 en
particular la iglesia la conferencia
episcopal suis obispos en Nicaragua
habían fungido como mediadores en un
diálogo entre el gobierno y entre los
representantes de las fuerzas que se
manifestaban de manera masiva en las
calles en contra del gobierno y en
contra de la represión estatal sin
embargo este diálogo se frustró el
gobierno no cumplió los acuerdos y desde
entonces Nicaragua se encuentra su vida
en una crisis socio política y económica